foreign
stepping into the guest seat Alex
harmozion I'm going to mess it up her
Mosey a first generation Iranian
American entrepreneur I just spent the
morning with him we did his podcast I
was a guest he's an investor a
philanthropist known for his expertise
in customer acquisition and monetization
it's a huge deal on YouTube has done
some amazingly large business deals
including scaled and exited seven
companies uh for in excess of 46 million
dollars so been a joy hanging out with
this young guy he's getting things done
1.3 million YouTube subscribers welcome
good to have you brother I'm honored to
be here well we're honored to have you
with us thanks for hanging out yeah this
is big I've been following you on
YouTube for a long time and then we had
Graham Stefan on I was on his show and
he was like you got to hang out with
Alex so you're on now and what's
interesting is that you mentioned in one
of your YouTube videos that Dave gave
Graham Stefan some of the wisest advice
you'd ever heard around investing and I
want you to share that so Graham was had
his big pie chart of his Investments on
the table he said Dave what am I doing
wrong here what should I be doing and
Dave rather than just like giving him
like oh you need to be 16 here and 13
here he said well if this pie chart were
your knowledge and expertise how would
you divide it up
he's like well I'd probably say him 85
real estate maybe like 15 like my
knowledge of stocks and that more or
less mirrored what Graham's actual
Investment Portfolio looked like and the
big takeaway that I had when I was
seeing that was it wasn't one particular
methodology it wasn't like oh you got to
get into stocks you got to get into
crypto you got to get into no obviously
like
I'm beating right
um but it was more so do what you know
and when my wife and I uh exited our
company and we had taken a sizable
distributions prior to that
um I hadn't really come up with an
investment strategy because the
investment strategy was in the beginning
don't be poor
um it's a good start I like that one but
then after that it was just like I had
everything in indexes and I wanted to
take a more active role and the only
thing I felt like I knew good enough was
business and so I had gone all the way
to the edge on you know two three four
big real estate transactions and right
before I needed to send the money I
pulled back so I was like I don't know
this stuff and so uh once I got
basically gave myself permission or I
felt like you'd give me some sort of
like verbal permission to just do what I
know
um acquisition.com kind of started and
became our family office for everything
that we do investing which is
exclusively businesses that we feel like
we can add value to yeah and it's it's a
space you know you're comfortable in you
should never put money in something that
you don't understand and don't know and
because some guy in a good suit said to
and the only thing he may own is a good
suit so that's probably not where we're
taking the advice so really that that's
really really really important okay so
you started with nothing
over 50 million dollar net worth in
excess of that on this one transaction
yeah I know you're probably north of 100
million at that point
um
and uh the Iranian
American so your parent your for your
first generation yeah first American
yeah okay so your parents came from Iran
both just my dad just your dad okay
mom's having a really good friend that
uh both of his parents came here and uh
also unbelievably successful uh and
financially and sometimes I think uh I
was talking to my friend Brian buffini
who's Irish and he has a book out called
The Immigrant Edge and so the mentality
that comes off that George's parents are
his second first generation Middle
Eastern Middle Eastern as well so uh uh
there's an immigrant Edge that goes with
that what is do you think the number one
mindset as you work with investors in
companies that keeps people broke
they subscribe to
what everyone else around them who is
poor tells them about how to get rich
so they take Poor People's advice on how
to make money hmm
and so as a result of that they keep
doing the wrong stuff or they don't do
anything at all and a lot of them sit
into this area of uh you know the
paralysis analysis they're like I need
to find the perfect thing and meanwhile
10 years later they're still trying to
wait to find the perfect thing and they
haven't started anything yeah
yeah how do you become a writer right
yeah how do you become an investor
invest yeah I used to because I I talk a
lot about sales stuff because I think
it's a really good entry uh thing for
anybody who wants to you know take
control of their own income and cost no
money to get into and all you have is
skill is that you know you can read 100
books on sales but the first thousand
cold calls you do you'll learn more than
all the books that that you read up to
that point experience as a mighty
teacher oh 100 and uh it's interesting
with skill proficiency but uh people
will put off you know it takes 20 20
hours of of concentrated work to become
proficient at most playing the guitar
playing the piano learning to do a cold
call 20 hour proficient of actual
dedicated work but people will wait a
decade to do those first 20 hours
because they're afraid
fears holding them back because they
don't want to fail a lot of the times
yeah they don't want the Judgment that
they think is coming along from people
who aren't actually paying attention to
them to begin with
uh multi-millionaire a young age
entrepreneur Alex Hermosa Our Guest this
segment you can catch him on YouTube uh
be sure and look that up uh that's
h-o-r-m-o-z-i if you don't know and you
can check him out at his website at
acquisition.com so what do you feel like
I mean you had a couple of really big
hits along the way
um the actual the liquidity event was a
big hit but the building up was gradual
and um I mean it wasn't like you had
like you hit the lottery and 20 minutes
had this kind of net worth but you so
you built a company sold it and that
that was a lot of it uh what do you
think all of that has taught you about
Building Wealth out there in America
today a is it possible and B what do you
think the your the sense of hope or the
sense of principles around it what did
you what's your takeaway
so a 100 possible B I think um I Define
sadness as ignorance as in you don't
know what options you have
and so like whenever you feel hopeless
it's because you don't know what to do
and so when I felt sad in my life I
think to myself like this is because I
don't know what to do which means that
this is a problem I can solve because
all I have to do is figure out what I
need to do and then that even gives me
my first action step which is like oh I
just don't know great and so
um for me solving that has been a
Perpetual education process and nowadays
there's so much free information that
exists on the internet like you can
learn how to flip houses you can learn
how to how to how to sell you can learn
how to code you can learn how to edit
videos like there are all these skills
that that pay entry-level roles 50 60 70
100 200 000 a year that you can learn in
eight weeks and so for the people who
are who are willing to just put in the
eight weeks and then apply for the jobs
you can get way ahead well there's a lot
of young people out there and you know I
get the messages they're 17 they're 18
they call into the show they're going
hey I want to invest I want to build
wealth I don't want to wait till I'm 60.
I don't want to work a job I hate do the
401K thing they want to make money
really quickly and a lot of times they
want to do it the wrong way what is the
advice you constantly give those folks
yeah so
um I say like you can invest in the S P
500 I was like but I prefer people
investing the SME 500 which is you're
always going to get higher Returns on
investing in your own education your own
skill set compared to any stock market
and so like a really real example of
this is a buddy of mine has a daughter
she's 17 I think she just turned 18.
um and she's she's working at a bowling
alley minimum wage job you know popcorn
right and
she said uh or he told her he's like you
know you can triple your income if you
just get a certification and become a
phlebotomist it takes two days it's 500
bucks
and by taking 500 she could invest in
the S P 500 and at 18 years old maybe it
would be a ton of compounding but if she
invests 500 in getting the certification
and then two days later she triples her
income
probably a better investment in buying
the certification than forever having a
three times higher Baseline for what she
can make and I think that's just like a
micro example of how much skills can
give you more cash flow to invest in
everything else and so my my belief is
always keep reinvesting the skills
because that raises your Lifeline your
your lifetime Baseline of earning
potential that's so good and valuable
valuable education uh is always costs
minuscule amounts not all education but
I said valuable usable utilitarian value
she can immediately go and do something
with that it's not like I collect
degrees for a living no this is like but
but studying something that is usable
100 of the time is the best investment
you can make my father came here with a
thousand dollars and he didn't speak
English but he had a medical degree
and so he's always been big on education
for me and if you look at it as an
actual investment I mean he fled during
the revolution in Iran he said they took
everything we had but they couldn't take
my education
and so it's something that can never be
taken from it from you you can't lose it
in divorce can't be taxed on it on your
your education itself it appreciates
with time and then the more educated
become the more valuable each prior
skill adds on top it compounds like if
you know how to do math then you can
then learn accounting when you learn
accounting then you can learn investing
and or business or whatever like each
one compounds unto itself